let me introduce our first guest the
director of ghost in the shell' give it
up for Rupert Saunders
hello Rupert hello I please have a seat
I feel like I should be an MMA fighter
absolutely absolutely okay so um welcome
to Japan
thank you is this your first time here
no I've been there a few times I see
okay and tell us about your visit here
and the relevance of having the this
event this press release here in Tokyo I
think really the first thing that we
wanted to do when we when we launched
the film was to come to the birthplace
of the film to show both the creators
the people who really started the whole
thing going that we were taking this
next chapter of the legacy very
seriously and that it wasn't going to be
something they'd be upset about they'd
be very proud of so it's important for
us to come here and say this is what
we've done this is what we're doing
we're not remaking we're reimagining but
we're reimagining with you alongside you
and it's it's a great honor and
privilege to work with with some of
these people it's great to hear Kenji
this evening and that really to me is
what's so great about what we did
tonight is to be able to hear the
original score with our new shelling
sequence so it's a real you know the
next chapter mm-hmm now our goes to the
shoulder to classic it's an icon what
does it mean to you and what do you plan
to bring it well what have you brought
into your vision of this piece um well
from Shiro's manga - oh she's anime to
come iammoz standalone complex
I didn't really have to do anything I
just stole from all of them and put it
together and off we go so my job is very
easy now in seriousness it's been a to
draw on something as seminal as that you
know I was a fan growing up so to me it
was an honor to take that stuff and you
know I try to my litmus test was do I
like what I'm doing you know my gut
check and if I was kind of inspired by
it then it it kind of stayed in the film
mm-hmm I see
um now GI TSL ghost in the shell' it's
been some time since the first appeared
in the manga but what would you say is
the relevance of ghost in the shell'
today I think in 95 for me first seeing
oshi's film was so ahead of its time and
I think really some of those ideas are
just catching up to us today I think
that there's so many elements of when we
are consumed by technology to the degree
we are where where does humanities sit
in that new kind of technological order
we trust so much into our devices as you
can see everyone's devised up we we tell
people where we are what we buy what we
shop who we talk to
and that goes somewhere and I think what
Ghost says there's a ghost of
information and Technology out there and
you know one of the points of the film
and one of the points of the the manga
and the anime was trusting in technology
and I think to me the the thing that I
try to kind of transmit through the film
is that there's hope in technology it's
not an evil thing it's something that if
we parent it right it will be part of us
as humans and we won't be obsolete um
what how would you describe the world
that you created in a ghost in the
shell' I think we set about trying to
create a very original take on the film
I think it's the thing that most people
when they see it are surprised about
it's very emotional it's a very
action-packed film it's got a lot of
crazy environments it's it's a future we
haven't seen before
but ultimately it's the journey of a
character who's who's trying to find
herself at first she's you know she's a
human brain in a machine a body so she's
trying to come to terms with
technologically what that is but
ultimately as the film moves forward
she's trying to understand not just what
she is but who she is see um how much
influence has the source material been
on making the version of Gita I thought
the opening was like incredible it was
you know the a real feature a live
feature of me I mean I think you know
there's so many as a fan myself there's
so many things in that film that I
wanted to you know
personally bring to life you know it was
it was fairly selfish endeavor I loved
that so much and I was able to draw from
so many great bits of inspiration I
think you know we wanted to make a globe
we wanted to bring goes to a huge
audience we wanted to bring it to a
global audience but we didn't want to
water it down we wanted to keep those
themes keep those ideas keep the
cyberpunk aesthetic to it very much
alive and I think scarlet as the major
really channels that that attitude and
that edge that I think is so much part
of her as an actress I see um again this
is a classic image on her arm did you
feel pressure in making this into a film
you feel pressure making any film but
Elliot's not it's all very glamorous
when you're here but most of our lives
is spent in the pouring rain and the mud
but I won't complain what's the question
pressure pressure pressure pressure it's
got to me yeah you know whenever you're
doing something in the public eye and
it's a very cherished um film and you
have to kind of silence it really you
know you can't you can't you can't you
can't read the blogs and take it at face
value you just have to say I'm lucky
enough to be in this position to do this
job I feel very strongly about the
legacy of ghosts I'm the next part of
that chapter and hopefully you know a
very long continuing story through
through the franchise of ghost in the
shell which is already a huge universe
so yes I felt pressure but you always
feel pressure as an artist and reiative
Lee in any endeavor you do so you just
have to do the best that you can do and
hope that the that is successful what
did you feel the most um some I'm sure
you had a set of athletics dealing with
us what is one point that you really
wanted to come across as far as the
spirit of the of the work I think that
the tone of you know it's hard when you
take a something like an anime or a
comic book or a manga from the the page
or from the animated frame into cinema
it's a bumpy trend
in a lot of the time and I think there's
successful cases and not such successful
cases but to me again it was you know it
was strong source material to work with
it was really just a question of tone
and the attitude of the film that I was
just trying to maintain that is that
ghost in the shell' when you're looking
at casting as that goes in the show
you're looking at a location as that
goes in the shell you know we designed
the world from from shoes up you know
there was a lot of kind of source
material to work with obviously but then
it's like well how do you bring that to
life and it doesn't feel strange because
it's being photographed as if there's a
there's a difficulty when you go from
from a comic book or anime to the cinema
I see now let's talk about the the
casting especially with a Scarlett
playing the role of major how did this
come about to me you know when I cast
very much from the gut and I think I was
I was very lucky to be able to get an
amazing international cast of people
that I always really wanted to work with
Scarlett was one of those people and to
me there's very few actresses who've had
20 years experience who have the
cyberpunk aesthetic already baked in you
know she comes from such edgy films from
lost in translation to under the skin
you know she's got an incredible body of
work and the attitude and the kind of
toughness of her really is to me the
major but also what she's done
incredibly in this film you see she's
playing an Android she's a synthetic
body with a with a human mind inside she
did an incredible job of nuancing the
human kind of evolving through through
the machine and in a way I think why
it's very related to a large audience
it's kind of a coming-of-age story and
it's it's it's a realization of I am
what I am whatever's happened to me good
or bad that is the sum of who I am now
I see um now some people of course them
it was anime and you brought it to real
life um some people might be critical
about the casting of Scarlett out the
major what do you have to say to that I
think whenever you cast someone people
someone's going to be critical about it
I mean to me it was you know I stand by
my decision she's the best actress of
her generation and I was I
flattered and honored that she would be
in this film and I think you know so
many people who around the original
anime have been very in support of her
because she's she's incredible and
they're very few like her now um did you
know of beat Takeshi come on you can
clap ha ha she's coming out later she
won a warm house now let's talk about
beat Takeshi um we did you know of him
before you cast him as aramaki yeah very
much so I I grew up on Hana be so
naughty and outrage I was you know I
guess it to me cinematically he was a
huge part of my growth as a filmmaker
kind of early on just watching those
films being like you know where did
those come from and I saw so much of his
work had been echoed in other films and
that came over to the West and it's
always great like finding a hip-hop
track and then you find the the rhythm
from a like an obscure kind of 60s
hippie band you like wow that's
incredible and it was kind of the same
with takeshi's like God I've seen all
that stuff before and that's where it
comes from
okay so he's like um the mother lode
almost oh yeah yeah he's an incredible
you know and when I was lucky enough to
be approached about this you know
Aramaki there was no one else who could
who could who could play Iraqi it was a
it took a while to get mr. mr. katana to
sign on the dotted line I will chase him
across the world I wanna get the paw
print that I got it but but you got your
guy I got him in the end yeah and he
does a wonderful job in the film and I
think what's amazing is he speaks
Japanese through the film and Scarlett's
major speaks speaks English it's a it's
a beautifully tender kind of fatherly
relationship and again it's you know it
just goes to the emotional strength of
the film and the kind of the legacy and
the heritage of this being a Japanese
property that's now a global global
manifesto no we're done please welcome
to the stage beat Takashi as dice don't
scare Aramaki
okay let me introduce him again a
Japanese icon be Takeshi is Daisuke are
Maki ladies and gentlemen 20 ja ah
what does make it this high so the chat
the small today Godin here lol Moses
dated extent away Messiah mr. Takeshi
are you a fan of ghost in the shell
oh no ma I'm acolyte oh my gosh I mean
ah anime polish turns I never saw the
shiny chorus i Dixit okey no no no no
toki niwa
shuttle elementary neva neva neva
without a subpoena tomentosa
Hong Kong Tokyo to toe my AI tapas
religious nah toaster stay aguar Hema
katana TG Italian - Tina not Oprah the
universe Martin's clothes Cunegonde is
some question kini ii yo ii yo g Dania a
low GI no sa flu taking I Omega yah -
yah yah conductor schedule not to use
talking ye cho Tata pay me no children
Gaurav Akiko Yoshida CO - yah yah yah no
sheshe tada no mother I mean yo get a
llama get on call me talk you don't
believe me Tanaka can I shuttle I got a
little more make some torsos I stay
coordinated Adams oh nice day Junior
yeah not totally to make the to me I say
um what excited you about being poor
this form
I know buddy
so y'know continue on Okinawa in a noon
noon felony sexual named cuca till the
mo how do you to a big old scarring
again in the category
aguado descended in area that stands
kiddo
sister ah no no such a joker Hollander
ah young Buddha come on I do not know
kundo Quatro cerejo my gallery titania
sister ah drop star is the sweet emoji
are you kill my knight or not they dare
not risk it and though even kondo-san la
chef no skirt to your hands Allah will
come to your Mata Tata you know for
laundry Keisha she did a great handle
that sorry I sent over universe not
listening it was just basically saying
that you know like he had some hard time
trying to do the lines in English so you
were kind enough to let him speak in
Japanese but then he goes I had some
problems memorizing the lines so he was
asking for prompter and he goes but the
best thing about doing this movie is
having a Scarlett Johansson putting up
his cue cards in front of him but she
thought was quite quite incredible it's
good say um now uh how would you just
try the character of aramaki ma hello
what motto tika ma
[ __ ] on concave ah no aircon Hongki
family no moto Keaton on second quédate
Otto
Serena McKenna una muchacha pani suede
escena han donto registra toy you know
yo home Otero - Juanita
today - Telugu stove - she look at the
more militant you are so know she's over
no you're not cacao
what's the you Jana honey don't you
finish to see so basically um mr. Takei
she said was uh again autumn buckets
characters both fatherly to the major
and yet ruthless and cold to his enemies
so that ambivalent of the warmth as
verses to coldest steel to have a
personality I guess is his take on the
character that he played now how was it
like working with Rupert as a director
uh no given money on deck and Reagan
Kentuckians na on yonder also know Ange
to you know to come in a box to you know
though hey shoot Oh Jim do I still there
Tizen desk anymore
mmm honey's don't waver in stange no she
doe welcome to gonna come in Ibaka
directo go photography Susie robbery
camel aa3 nice and a guy on dialysis I
go down good a girl dead local elite the
cruise dog eat a sandwich reproduction
friendly 300 kilometer high because so
know hey Siobhan Tina my day
Selena Mota Iran day Sasha skills to you
Yuna and I'm there Hulu comfortable
under content indoctrination is no more
so no do ki tarah Tanisha - Oleg are not
para a Telugu no even I know Katya Nova
epithelial shot to stay yoni tie ended
on day three I'd attempt to talk to you
cut you down dr. birthday not so busy of
a such a case was basically saying um he
when he takes us movies he would be
directing it he'd be editing and he'd be
doing all the
were himself but in this production
there's the director Rupert and then you
also have the the editor the editing
director and you have the director
photography every has their own position
of a job the responses that they have to
do and it was quite amazed at how many
how many cuts how many shots was taken
for one scene and Rupert actually told
him that was for the editor the editing
director to be able to choose from all
the mirrors of choices that they could
select a nice about that was quite
surprising or different from the mode
that he was used to now on what
impressed you mr. Takeshi the most about
working on this film New Zealand oh oh
brother waiting Tony good guy you lit up
she don't walk up top I see
plane ride in New Zealand was very very
shaky I got yeah
ladies and gentlemen the star of ghosts
of the show Scarlett Johansson
have a seat please welcome to Japan
Charlotte how's it feel to be back in
Japan oh I loved I loved Tokyo it's such
a great city and the last time I had the
chance to work here I was much younger
than today I'm 17 and you know every
time I've returned here it actually it
feels familiar to me I think because I
had those you know very early days here
right that's a it's a wonderful city I
love it I say thank you very much now um
were you aware of ghost in the shell Oh
prior to being cast no I actually I
didn't know the material and I when the
script came to me it also came with a
copy of the anime and you know when I
first saw it I it seemed quite daunting
um I think because you know the anime is
so philosophical and I didn't know how
it would exactly translate to a
live-action film er really what I could
contribute to it exactly um but it was
alluring definitely a Lawrence um you
just mentioned alluring what was a
luring about the role you played the
major you know when I met with Rupert
and I I'd been sent this pretty
impressive visual presentation it was
just absolutely magnificent and I think
you'll see the result of it shortly but
you know we started to talk about the
journey of the major and and and how the
character was going to be driving the
story um and I started to imagine that
this was a character who was really
living who was really living a very
unique experience of somebody who has an
idea of who she thinks she was and then
who she is now the life she's living now
and then this then the person that she
feels she is this sort of gnawing
clawing feeling she has in her in her
ghost and the that being able to kind of
play these three sides you know we
called it the sort of the ego and the
super-ego in the in yeah and that that
was really that was pretty enticing for
me
right okay so I guess some what goes on
inside is extremely complicated as far
as the character the major is concerned
but how how did you train for again it's
a very cerebral part and yet you must be
very physical what kind of training did
you do for this role
um I mean of course I did a lot of
training just because I wanted to be
able to have the physical presence of
somebody who seemed very capable and
then of course I had to actually be
quite capable and luckily I have had a
lot of fight training and weapons
training for all those little Marvel
movies so it comes quite in handy
because the vocab you kind of know a
physical cab you Larry and then and then
did a lot of you know it's a lot of
repetition and then a lot of tactical
training which I'd never done before
like room-clearing and all that stuff to
just be as efficient with the weapon as
possible hmm I see now how was it
working with Rupert you know what Rupert
and I had I think from the very
beginning we were really dedicated to
our partnership because it may not we
think we both knew very early in those
early days that we would have to do this
walking hand in hand in order to
maintain the integrity of the work and
what we had set out you know this kind
of mission statement that we made in the
beginning and I think you know again
when I see the pieces of the film I see
the result of that teamwork really so we
were each other's partner for sure um
how was it working with the Takeshi I I
mean I think when you work with somebody
who
has been so great for such a long time
you kind of stand back and observe and
you know it's it's interesting I I feel
that you know acting it's kind of a you
know as Rupert was saying earlier of
course Takashi was speaking Japanese I
was speaking English but um you know
acting is such a it's it's human you
know it's all about what's going on
inside and you know I felt so many
complicated things you know in in our
Mackey's presence um you know sort of a
feeling of you know shame at times a
feeling of you know wanting to an
eagerness to please and then also
feelings at times like a petulant child
and having all of these feelings acting
opposite somebody we didn't share this
language but we share the universal
language is kind of you know this which
is just the the emotional you know
vocabulary that we have his two actors
it was it was very moving so he felt
that maybe being professionals and
theatre and acting kind of transcended I
guess language I guess so that's kind of
communicated into universal language so
totally absolutely that's that's the
beauty I think of being able to work on
a film as diverse as this because you
really you know you're working with
actors from many different backgrounds
theater backgrounds some are you know
are working in dance others are you know
in photography and it was really you
know we all shared the same the kind of
that connectivity that right that we all
you know that we that kind of brings us
together I think see now what would you
say to so many fans throughout the world
to all the fans of ghosts Nichelle
looking to tell them what what do you
want them to expect what do you want
them to feel I know I think for me I
have such a soft spot for the major of
course because I enter our journey of
self-discovery and I think this film for
me is really even though it's
that in this explosive world with you
know that's just extraordinary and it's
so visually stunning and it's so
action-packed it's really to me a story
that's it's a coming-of-age story and a
story about you know the loss of
innocence and then also the kind of
rebirth that you can have from that and
I hope that the fans connect with the
major the way that the way that I
connected with her her journey so to
speak yeah okay now um I have some more
questions to Rupert
tell me I'd like to ask you a few more
questions considering the movie Juliette
Binoche she's in the movie can you tell
us about her part what role she plays
Juliette pliat plays the head of hanka
robotics which created the major and she
in a way is the creator and the mother
of the major I see okay and tell us
about the role that Michael Pitts plays
um Michael well you give a lot away when
you start talking about characters so
it's suffice to say that he's he's
involved in the film and quite a quite a
substantial way and he's a he's a
thrilling actor to watch and I think him
and Scarlett some incredible scenes
together very very dramatic very moving
also with Kaori Mamu in the audience
somewheres and I had a legendary actor
really beautiful to watch her as well we
were very lucky a Rila Fukushima and
other another actress who's with us here
tonight we we we really kind of bonded
in our little island on the other side
of the worlds and I'm cut off from from
our loved ones we were in there kind of
battling in the trenches every day and
we had a great diverse group of
wonderful actors so we enjoyed ourselves
actually so even behind the scene there
was a ghost in a shocked communities you
guys kind of share the same mindset oh
you're like a circus when you work in
film you know you you pitch your tent
and you stay there for a year and then
you drink all the bars dry any all the
restaurants dry and then you you go off
to the next one
I see now arm as much as you can divulge
can you tell us about the characters
a comprise section nine yeah I mean
sections major is a is a is a human
brain in a synthetic body and she was
built to head section nine so section
nine really are tasked with tracking
down a ruthless and murderous cyber
terrorist and that's kind of the A's
story the projection story of the film
but the film has a lot more than just
that you know I think like like great
film noir you have a detective story
that drives you forward but what always
happens in in film noir is an emotional
journey of self-discovery and a lot of
kind of action and you know for us the
world is so amazing and I think
cinematically I think it'll be a very
fresh fresh take on on futurism that
people haven't seen before there's a lot
of the anime there there's a lot of the
manga there but there's also an updating
and a reappraisal of that I see scarlet
can you add something to how you felt
about the movie in general if you would
like to kind of make a final view of
what your experience in this movie ah
gosh that's such a loaded question
because it was such a cop it was I feel
I grew a lot when I made making this
film I learned a lot about my um my
limitations I learned a lot about my
capability and I think when you play a
character that is some step removed from
human and you are and you don't have the
nuance and the tools of you know those
things those little things that make us
human it's it's it's very it's just a
very challenging experience because
there's so much going on inside but
what's going on inside is it's
impossible to reflect completely outside
so that pairing a way of that was just a
very it was a very unique experience for
me and uh and so it's impossible to kind
of
to put it all into a logline but I'm
very proud of the work that we did and
you have been within the John you've
you've played several roles within the
genre so I guess again this is a new
challenge for you something I've never
experienced before
certainly it was something I'd never
experienced before and I think I've
pushed the genre all the way I can't see
it okay I don't know I did of did I was
a I was a person without a body now I'm
a brain without a body
mmm maybe next time I need a body and a
brain together yeah we'll see okay now
Rupert we're gonna be playing the
trailer next would you like to add a few
words before we watch the trailer um I I
think I just like to thank everyone for
coming out tonight really - you know
this has been a big part of our launch
in the film to come to Tokyo and not to
do it and in somewhere somewhere else it
was very important to us to come here
I'm very thankful that people came to
see I'd like to thank mr. Nomura of
cadencia a mr. Shekhar of IG who really
partnered with us to bring this to the
world you know it's a very hallowed
property here and I think hopefully you
know the sounds of ghost in the shell
will resonate around the world and come
back to Tokyo and come back to Japan the
Japanese people and I hope that they
feel that that we have respected and
honored the heritage of ghost in the
shell and a proud of what they see on
the screen okay son
hey what I'll totally let me remind you
all the guys think this killable I have
to say it in English first mister
Takeshi would you like to add a few
words before we watch the trailer ah
chotto de que es da me cinta de todos
que no more hallelujah Joe tanto ya know
crazy play Organic economist watch
annoying ah helpful great evening
tonight at the gray sequoias da Frigga
are you askin
a toy a funny candle Solano toxemia took
our mmm you don't know figure no
designer Luis Octonauts Kruger yeah
buddy
so I gotta know so again cinema on Tony
Cottee Vashta hey ma for insanity Sokoto
huntin
Rashida's is oh thank you Tara she need
a fake okay thank you very much um
Scarlett can you give one last message
to your fans about how great this movie
is I think it's always my hope winner
when when making a film that you um you
know you have that you know you connect
with people in that dark theater and
they're able to escape into some other
world that we've created for them you
know my hope for the fans is that they
get taken on a ride that is not just
explosive and exciting but also you know
allows them to be reflective and and and
and to be you know curious more curious
about themselves from watching this film
so I I hope it resonates that that
deeply with them
you